on prouve
qu'on peut vivre ensemble que la
différence n'est pas un froid que c'est
plutôt une richesse
[Musique]
et moi je suis une femme
mais il me faudrait un homme
[Musique]
du Sénégal
est un état de l'Afrique de l'Ouest
[Musique]
venez à qui de Nice le triptyque d'un
volet on avait commencé déjà en 2005
avec trois hommes un village ensuite en
2010 avec trois femmes un village et
puis maintenant 13 ans après 2023 avec
bienvenue à Kiki Denis toujours le même
concept là cohabitation et de religions
par rapport à l'actualité on traite de
l'aspect de la sécurité donc on va
parler de l'aspect sécuritaire aussi et
la tolérance interligieuse donc c'est
autant de thèmes toujours sur un ton
comique beaucoup d'humour dedans donc
voilà un peu une satire
[Musique]
faut pose-moi réfléchir à au scénario à
son contenu n'est pas le traité par
rapport seulement au seul burkinabè mais
l'ouvrir
à l'univers parce que tous les problèmes
qui sont posés ici c'est des problèmes
universels finalement
qu'on parle de
d'intégrisme qu'on parle de sécurité
qu'on parle de cohésion sociale de vivre
ensemble c'est partout aujourd'hui c'est
la grande question que ce soit en Europe
que ce soit dans les Amériques que ce
soit en Afrique aujourd'hui c'est la
grande question comment faire pour vivre
ensemble
[Musique]